[Applause]
all right welcome back to Hannity we
continue with our live studio audiences
Friday night now it's time for the
Hannity hot seat and we are joined by
two of the six house members those that
have been against Kevin McCarthy in
every vote to date now the question
tonight is will their opposition
continue in the next vote which is
likely in less than an hour and joining
us now Colorado congresswoman Lauren
bobert and Florida Congressman Matt
Gates uh good to see you both I've been
in contact with you both this week uh
Matt
once or twice by the way Laura
congresswoman can we settle something we
had a passionate debate this week we did
now I welcome you to get passionate like
that all the time because
laurenforfreedom.com blew up
I hope I've raised a lot of money for
your next campaign or helped you raise
money but I said to you during that
debate it you know it's interesting how
people pursue receive things I said
there's probably very little we disagree
on and where I was frustrated was well
you didn't answer the question and I
have a pet peeve about that but it's not
we I've never been opposed to you and I
said on the air the next day I said no
we were texting after the after the
debate and I said no we're friends we
just had a disagreement in terms of
whether or not the agenda items were in
cement I thought there were did you
perceive it the same way
uh Sean I thought it was a very
exhilarating debate that we had and
usually I'm one of the 20 people who are
opposing something and you are cheering
on so you know we just were on a
different side on this issue and then
you know of course there were others on
the show like Trey Gowdy that said that
um we were on there just for personal
gain and holding out for that and
nothing could be further from the truth
myself Matt Gates and every single one
of the 20 conservatives that demanded
these changes did so for the good of the
country full stop where are you tonight
on Kevin McCarthy
uh well I believe that when this is all
over everyone from the speaker's office
to my more moderate colleagues even
friends and Alex at uh allies that I've
exchanged uh some tough words with like
yourself we will work together to
deliver historic fundamental changes in
DC we will have conservative Solutions
on important issues facing the American
people so we'll see how tonight goes I
think that there are some things that we
need to get locked in and make sure that
we are able to deliver on these promises
are you confident Say by Monday the
latest that this will be over and Kevin
will be the speaker and you will have
the assurances that you need that all
the agenda items you have campaigned on
and that you fought for are going to be
implemented by the new Congress
I sure hope by Monday we see something
um something that is promising to
deliver for the American people and I
truly believe that after months of the
negotiations that we've seen and a few
extra days even of being assembled on
the house floor Republicans are going to
be far more prepared to lead and more
prepared to govern than ever before Matt
Gates where are you tonight
well Sean this has never been about me
or Kevin McCarthy it's about the
American people and the American people
want to know that the rules of the House
of Representatives would never allow
something like this terrible horrendous
Omnibus Bill to ever pass ever again and
that's what congresswoman bobert and I
have been working on and while I know
that sometimes these discussions can be
a little awkward up front I guess it's I
guess it's like a prenuptial agreement
that you'd be preparing sometimes there
can be some uncomfortable moments in the
preparation but it can be necessary I am
excited and encouraged I am grateful
that speaker designate McCarthy has been
so receptive to each and every change
that we have demanded and Sean we're at
the stage right now where I'm running
out of stuff to ask for I mean read the
bills have a balanced budget have a
border plan Kevin McCarthy is agreeing
to all these things and again it's never
been about him it's been about draining
the swamp making this a more honest
transparent open place and we may have a
few things finishing touches we may be
able to get this resolved tonight but I
am proud of the entire Republican
conference and we're going to be
stronger and more unified and more able
to hold this Administration accountable
because we have had these early moments
of sorting things out so we had
communication from in December pretty
early in December and you're free to
talk about anything you want
um and my admonition to a number of
people because I saw all of this coming
I would have preferred that it happened
before January 3rd we ultimately seem to
have gotten there was I wrong in
anticipating that this was headed in
this direction would it have been better
to maybe do it behind closed doors well
Sean I love you but if I would have
voted for speaker McCarthy when you
asked me to on Monday we wouldn't have
the spending caps we wouldn't have
that's not what I asked you for members
so I would say you may leave me but
that's what I asked you we did very well
driving a hard bargain what I said was
as I said I correct me if I'm wrong I
wanted everybody early on way before
January 3rd to get in a room lock the
door check their egos check your phone
fight it out behind closed doors and be
ready on January 3rd now with that said
you know what there's none of this has
ever bothered me I think at the end if
this would go on another week I think it
would drive the American people nuts but
ultimately it is the agenda to save this
country this country is in a mess the
Democrats have run this country into a
ditch this President doesn't know what
day it is look at the debt look at
energy policy look at our our borders
our Southern borders this we need a
United Republican party to fight hard I
think we now have that is that a fair
statement Matt Gates I really think that
we are coalescing around that Vision I'm
very optimistic about where we are right
now but we simply would not allow
business as usual to continue and that
wasn't and personal toward anyone that
was a problem with Washington that
existed under both Republicans and
Democrats and Lauren bobert and I hear
from our constituents that they want
this town to change and these
fundamental changes if we can get the
finishing touches on them they will far
Outlast Lauren bobert and I they will
far Outlast Kevin McCarthy and they will
be there to deliver the Amer for the
American people and stop these terrible
spending bills that are pushing our
country into debt I think we all agers
of the Next Generation I think we just
disagreed at different points I know
things have been agreed to behind closed
doors and maybe it didn't filter down to
the rank and file but also people did
want an agreement they wanted it in
writing they wanted greater commitments
I really don't fault anybody for that at
the end of the day it's about the
country it's about serving your
constituents it's about the American
people and serving them they are the
people that would get hurt if you don't
do your job uh anyway uh Congressman
Gates always great to have you
congresswoman bobert you know what thank
you for having a passionate debate and
we fully support your candidacy already
I'm endorsing you for your next term
okay so everybody knows thank you so
much I hope people still go to
laurenforfreedom.com even when it's
peaceful yeah sure why not I'm coming on
Hannity I might as well get a plug-in
for the website my next election I love
it hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else